find the perimeter of a rectangle with
the length and width given below express
your answer as a simplified rational
expression and state the domain so just
as a little bit of a review the
perimeter is just the distance around
the rectangle and so if it has length w
and with sorry length l and with w the
perimeter is going to be this length
plus w plus this length again plus w
again or the perimeter is going to be 2
times the length because you have to add
the length twice
2 times the length plus 2 times the
width since you're adding the width
twice
so let's just use this expression with
these expressions right over here and
then simplify it so our perimeter is
going to be equal to 2 times our length
so that's we could write it as 2 times
2x plus 5y
over
x plus 4
plus 2 times the width plus 2 times the
width is right here x minus 3y
over
x plus 4. now immediately we can
constrain the domain the only number
that will not work
for the for x here is the number that
will make either of these denominators 0
and that number is negative 4. if x was
negative 4 then the denominator would be
0 and these would be undefined so we'll
constrain the domain we'll say x cannot
be equal to
negative 4 and then we can simplify from
there the first thing i do is i just
distribute this 2 on the numerator so
this is 2 times 2x plus 5y is
4x
plus 10y
and all of that's over x plus 4
plus now distribute this 2. 2 times x
minus 3y is 2x
minus 6y just multiplied both terms by 2
over x plus 4 and not x plus y x plus 4
over x plus 4 and we have to remember x
cannot be equal to negative 4.
now we want to add these two rational
expressions and lucky for us we have
this we already have a common
denominator so we don't have to find a
common denominator so this is going to
be the same thing this is going to be
equal to i'll just do it right here
scroll down a little bit
we have a common denominator of x plus 4
and then we could add the x terms up
here so we're going to have the 4x let
me do that another color
we have
the 4x being added to the 2x
so that is going to be equal to 6x and
then we have the 10y
being added to a negative 6 wires
negative or 6y being subtracted from 10y
depending how you want to view it so
that is plus
4y and of course we're still
constraining our domain x cannot be
equal to negative 4. so that's our
simplified expression for the parameter
you could factor out a 2 here if you
want not clear which one is more
simplified i'd argue that this one is
but you could write this as 2 times 3x
plus 2y
just factoring out a 2 over x plus 4
over x plus 4 where once again x cannot
be equal to negative 4.